근데 현금을 가지고 계신 분들은
오히려 지금이 좀 더 기회인 거
[음악]
같아요네 안녕하세요 빌사남 있니다 어
제가 오늘은 2024년 어 빌딩 시장
전망에 대해서 오늘 좀 얘기를 해
보겠습니다 어 우선 내년 전망
결론부터 좀 말씀드리면 어 내년
전망도 좀 좋지 않을 것으로 예상이
됩니다 그 이유 중에 가장 큰게 바로
고금리가 어 좀 계속 이어지면서 빌딩
거래량이 더 늘 거 같은 않습니다
지금 연주에서도 좀 금리를 당장
내리거나 어 그럴 것 같지 않아서 좀
계속이 고금리가 좀 이어질 것으로 좀
예상이 되고요 두 번째 같은 경우에는
빌딩 임대 시장이 좀 좋지 않아요
작년 같은 경우에도 그래도 좀 뭐 통
임대라는 임대가 좀 되긴 했는데 이제
올해부터는 뭐 빌딩 임대 시장이 좀
좋지 않습니다 회사들도 많이 좀
이렇게 폐업하거나 뭐 이런 경우는 좀
많고 그리고 신규 투자 유치가 좀
많이 안 돼요 그래서 뭐 진짜
유동성이 좀 활발할 때는 뭐 신규
투자받는 업체들이 워낙 많았기 때문에
뭐 확장 이전하거나 이런 수요들이 좀
굉장히 많았는데 최근에는 신규 투자
위치라든가 돈이 좀 많이 안 돌기
때문에 뭐 새로 사무실을 구하거나 뭐
이전하는 경우가 좀 많이 준 거
같습니다 그리고 2021년
2022년도에 뭐 신축이나 리모델링
했던 건물들이 지금 이렇게 완성되는
경우가 있거든요 그래서 그런 공급이
좀 많이 생겨나면서 좀 임대 시장이
더 안 좋아지는 거 같습니다 이런
점들 때문에 내년에도 좀 빌딩 시장이
좋지 않을 것 같고 만약에 내년에
빌딩 투자를 한다라고 했을 때는
아무래도 고금리가 좀 계속 이어지다
보니까 대출은 좀 최소한 도로 받는
걸 좀 권해드립니다 저금리 시대 때야
뭐 이렇게 뭐 영에서 사든 뭐
레버리지를 좀 많이 이용했는데 그래서
지금 같은 시기에는 내가 감당이
가능한 진짜 최소한의 대출 이용해서
투자하는 걸 좀 거 해드리고 싶고 어
제 개인적인 생각은 뭐 비율로 보자면
한 매매가에 한 30에서 50% 뭐이
정도가 좀 적정
선이지만게 빌딩에서 가장 중요한 거는
그 땅의 가치를 파악하는게 제일
중요해요 그래서 지금 뭐 수익률이 몇
프로냐 뭐 임차인이 뭐 뭐가 들어왔냐
뭐 대지 평단가가 얼마냐 뭐 이것도
중요하긴 하지만 제일 중요한게이 땅의
가치가 진짜 얼마가
용도 지역이 뭔지 지금은 뭐 2
3층짜리 건물이지만 나중에 건물을 멸
실해서 더 올릴 수 있는지 아니면은
뭐 4층짜리 건물인데 뭐 증축이
가능한지 뭐 이런 땅의 가치를
파악하는게 제일 중요하거든요 그
건물이이 땅의 용도에 맞게 최대로
활용하고 있냐 이게 되게
중요하거든요네 그래서 여러분들이 빌딩
투자하는데 제일 중요한게이 땅의
가치를 파악하는게 제일 중요합니다
그리고 마지막으로 제가 한 거의 한
뭐 100번 이상 얘기한 거 같은데
금성입니다 그래서 내가 찾는
금액대가 어떤 지역 그 어떤 동에
제일 매각이 많이 되는지가 제일
중요한 거 같아요 쉽게 설명드리면
제가 만약에 뭐 옷을 이제 판매한다고
생각했을 때 어떤 지역에 어떤
수요층을 대상으로 가게를 열어서 옷을
팔지를 좀 생각해 보잖아요네 빌딩도
비슷해요네 어떤 지역에 어느 정도
수요층이 있고 내 어떻게 만들어서
팔아야지 나중에 매각이 될지를 알아야
됩니다 처음 들어갈 때부터 예 단순히
그냥 지금 수익률 몇 % 뭐 임대
임차인이 뭐가 들어왔는지 그것만 보고
판단할게 아니라 건물을 사서 나중에
이제 상품으로 만들었을 때 매각이 될
만한 지역의 건물을 사셔야 됩니다 뭐
요즘 같은 시기에는 워낙 그 환금성이
중요하기 때문에 만약에 내년에 빌딩을
사신다 그러면이 부분을 좀
기억하셨다가 투자하면 좋겠습니다 좀
정 정리를 해보자면 아무래도 내년은
빌딩 시장이 좋지 않기 때문에 좀
거래량이 더 뭐 폭발적으로 늘어나거나
뭐 그럴 거 같지 않지만 근데 현금을
가지고 계신 분들은 오히려 지금이 좀
더 기회인 거 같아요 예전에 뭐
2021년 2022년 도에는 진짜
건물이 있어도 사지 못했거든요 갑자기
건물 안 판다 그러거나 갑자기 계약
자리에서 금액을 올리거나 근데 요즘
같은 시장에는 어찌됐든 매수인 위
시작이기 때문에 금액 협상이 좀 돼요
금액 협상이 되거나 아니면 다른
조건들이 되게 좀 좋은 조건으로
되거든요 그래서 여러분들이 만약에
내가 지금 현금 있다라고 하면은
오히려 더 좀 좋은 기회지 않나
싶습니다 그래서 어 지금 고금리가
이어진지가 불가 얼마 안 됐어요
그래서 작년 거의 하반기부터 이제 좀
폭발적으로 많이 올랐는데 금리가
아직까지는 그래도 좀 버티신 분들이
있긴 하지만 이게 지금 거의 뭐 계속
내년까지 이어진다고 하면 저는
무리하게 대출받거나 아니면 기존
임차인이 지금 상황이 좋지 않는
임차인도 꽤 있거든요 그래 그런
임차인들이 임대료를 못내는 경우도
있어요 그래서 대출이자 감당이 안 돼
그리고 제가 앞서 설명드린 그 영상에
법인이 이게 마이너스가 찍히면
은행에서 대출 연장이 안 되고
은행에서 대출을 갚으라 그래요 그렇게
문제 있는 법인들 던지는 매물들이 좀
나올 것 같습니다 내년에 그래서
현금을 가지고 계신 분들이라면 어
내년 시장이 좀 되게 좋은 시장이
아닐까 그래서 만약에 내년에
투자한다고 하면 제가 말씀드린이
포인트들을 좀 기억하셨다가 투자를
하셨으면 좋겠습니다 그래서 오늘 영상
여기까지 하고요 어 다음 시간에
뵙도록 하겠습니다 여러분
안녕히계세요